paraded in front of cameras until they
can go home these are some of the 350
captives released by ho thieves
it's an overwhelming sense of delight
happiness and pleasure as I am coming
home back to my family we hope for the
release of all prisoners and detainees
from all sides simply because we are
Yemenis and all the prisoners and their
families are suffering they were on the
last drone under a un-brokered prisoner
swap agreement signed in Stockholm in
December the deal to release 7,000
detainees was seen as a breakthrough
towards peace but the Yemeni government
and the Houthis have blamed each other
for failing to implement it houses say
this unconditional release should show
their commitment we are prepared and
willing for an all-inclusive swap deal
whether they are Yemenis or other
nationalities and to prove our sincerity
we have initiated the unconditional
release of 350 prisoners we have called
the United Nations to pressure the other
side to reciprocate among those being
held our Saudi citizens who the healthy
say will be handed over to the Red Cross
according to how these the release of
350 prisoners is another gesture of
goodwill after their initiative to halt
drone and missile attacks inside Saudi
Arabia but they say that hasn't stopped
the Saudi UAE a late coalition from
attacking targets in Yemen aid workers
have called for guest chairs like this
as a way to build confidence with hopes
that it can lead to a peaceful
resolution the people who were released
today we're fathers sons brothers of
course we hope to see more initiatives
in the future bitter numbers from all
sides and as the International Committee
of the Red Cross we are always ready to
act as a neutral facilitator just as we
did today in any future release
operation
so definitely we are hopeful and we also
hope that this release we've contributes
to the revival of the Stockholm
agreement in a media briefing on Monday
this spokesman for the Saudi UAE
equality was non-committal on releasing
captives in response to the Houthis
freeing hundreds of fighters according
to how the military spokesman they
launched a major attack inside the Saudi
territory of Nasrin and destroyed
multiple vehicles as well Houthis say
they show the capture of hundreds of
Yemeni and Saudi soldiers al Jazeera
cannot independently verify the videos
the Saudi spokesman also cautioned
against taking these videos at face
value
the Houthis criticized world powers for
condemning the attack and said oil is a
commodity which is not more expensive
than Yemeni blood coming up al Jazeera